there's a lot of mismatches you know
it's just it is what it is but you made
a great night of fights meaning you need
some dope ass Knockouts dope finishes
and if there's an upset hell yeah it
could be card of the year but everything
goes according to the way Vegas odds has
it you're gonna you're gonna have a
landslide man
what is poppin it is Monday July 3rd
happy Fourth of July if you're watching
this on Tuesday
the summer holiday
Extravaganza is here
a lot of fireworks it's just not the
same when we were kids is it I used to
go buy fireworks it was so lit no you
can't it's too many forest fires and you
still buy fireworks and you bought some
last year I bought some for you you
didn't use them though right I know it's
illegal I know they're too crazy so it's
a good thing you didn't use it nice try
I still have a huge box nice try I'm not
going to use you still have a huge box
that they fly like crazy that's what you
want man yeah like my kids have not like
they just watch them in the sky they
have no idea the danger [__] we used it
is dangerous oh my God it was fun it was
so fun you can't do any of it like you
can't you can't even do steaks and like
sparklers I think you can do those but
I'm not sure what you see I don't know
but you can't there's nowhere to buy
them unless you're going like outskirts
like Vegas Wyoming that's true since
I've been living around here I don't see
any places they used to pop up
everywhere everywhere there's just like
fireworks didn't go in there parking
lots grab the basket my dad just has put
stuff in there like can we get this one
like that big like weird like black cat
thing with like this dragon on it you'd
like my God damn laughing dude so fun
man sure some people got burnt and lost
the knife it was all lost hands yep arms
oh yeah I remember that uh football
player for the Jets blew his hand off
with I think it was like an M80 though
m80s are just little things of dynamite
yeah pretty much boy we were living
though man it was fun so a guy lost a
hand come on man someone threw a M80
into you know when I went to PE in high
school so I went through it and made in
the stall next to me as I'm peeing yeah
Cherry Bomb would call it and I couldn't
hear for like I don't know like 10
minutes or something I was scared that I
lost my you know that's like most death
from uh Italian job that's what happened
to him oh really in that movie okay yeah
but kids just have no clue man Fourth of
July used to be so lit now here watch
these in the sky
they don't know you guys do anything for
the fourth nah
nah I'm at barbecue we kind of did the
big family Barbecue yesterday in pool
it's chill I mean yeah it's dope though
it's all good it's all good I was fresh
off the road from Covina Covina
California shout out to Covina uh
I I've never been there I got to be
honest I haven't heard of it it's about
45 minutes away there's big David Lucas
joined me for it
um yeah it was fun man it was fun for
sure
um covina's dealt it's a dope little
area and I will definitely be back new
club out there Laugh Factory they got
one out there man it's like a little
theater it was really dope so definitely
back shut to Covina it's a great spot
man and I didn't feel like a road gig
because I was driving back every night
only took 45 minutes to get back home
but shout out to Covina had some great
pizza
the with the Cody bro Sean Cody who
played at USC then played eight years in
the NFL I think for the lines he was on
the like oh and 16 Lions team you don't
have to look them up okay but uh him and
his brother open a pizza shop called I
think it's trap Pizza not like trap
house but t-r-a-p pizza man is it good
good pizza that's all the people
recommend was pizza and coffee so we had
trap Pizza we had uh Devil's Pizza which
was good but trap pizza was fantastic
man so if you're in Covina area go check
out trap pizza and the gray 8 Sean Cody
and his big bro big bro they're both
thick Boys on that pizza joint so go
check it out as far as the fight game
goes you had a uh you had a you know not
a great card
um but you did have Sean Strickland
doing it just beating up another
dagestanian via Germany magimetov uh he
melted this dude and on paper and
there's a reason why Strickland was a
favorite but you on paper you look at uh
magomerov's the way he fights his style
his skill level even though he hasn't
fought at a super high level but I think
the dude's 21 20-1
you'd see I could post some problems for
Sean Strickland and he's a big dude too
he's 25-5 he's a he's a big dude bigger
than Sean
um good wrestling good overall skill set
first first fight in UFC
Spartan kicked homeboy Dustin in the
face in the first round 19 seconds dude
was a beast and Sean Strickland just
melts these dagestanians dude just melts
them I mean I thought this could be a
tough matchup I would maybe go five
rounds and strictly Edge it out maybe
dude he's melted homeboy just his
pressure and I don't think I've ever
seen a daddy standing like just mentally
break like that he just beat the [__]
out of this kid
now you're saying he goes yeah I think I
deserve a shot against uh is he
and when I heard first my initial
reaction right here I'm like ah that
doesn't make too much sense because you
looked at his last two his last three
fights right he lost a can there they
took that fight on a short notice beat
the [__] out of another Savage most
people don't know in uh uh emmanov right
beat him
um and then he gets this Margaret off
everyone's like who is this cat and he
look at him like Jesus Christ starches
him uh before that obviously lost to
Pierre that one's whatever that happens
the Jared came there split decision so
it's not too bad
um
but when you look at the state of the
middleweight division it's like I could
see him I could see him definitely get
it you know because obviously there's a
big indicator with Robert Whittaker and
du plessis this Saturday which we'll get
into
um and there's a reason do policies jump
kind of jumped the queue a little bit
he's fighting Robert Whittaker but they
want to please he's worse Izzy they need
fresh meat for Izzy that's why Alex
Pierre got fast tracked that's why Sean
Strickland they thought was good you
know if you beat can there who's gonna
get the title shot
um they're trying to get fresh meat for
Izzy because he's beat everybody
everybody some of them he's beat him
twice sometimes you know he's beat him
three times you know so it's like
there's not a lot of meat for Izzy up
there so they're trying to find
narratives Sean stricken could be a good
narrative they have that trash talk back
at what you UFC whatever it was one of
the same card
um I I definitely I prefer Sean
Strickland over I can't say that I'm big
fan if Robert Whittaker gets done he
deserves a title shot
tough to do that one but yeah you kind
of have to yeah what is she gonna do I
know so but if it's not Whittaker you
could see Strickland getting a shot did
you look at the other guys as he's beat
everybody you know you think do policies
is better you look at the top I think do
police rank six you look at the top five
or tell me duplicities has more skill
than those other guys we're talking
about I think two places two policees
Victoria's a fun one
um
can an aired be a good matchup uh
Whitaker is a nightmare for him off the
ox appears not even middleweight anymore
but there's some tough matchups
duplication will be a fun one that'd be
a really fun one I'm not mad at that but
they're just trying to figure out like
what to do for Izzy up there they just
need contenders but Robert Whittaker
clear-cut should get a Top Shot if he
beats to policies
um yeah Sean Strickland just that dude
just melts them just melts them and
gives you hot takes on the pre-fight
oppressors and the post fight pressers
coming in hot dude super hot I mean
coming hot sponsor like nah man nah man
you better enjoy that win money because
we ain't paying sponsors like Monsters
like
but you know he's I think he's he's
refreshing
he's he's refreshing till he's not like
right now it's cool and he's you know
firing off the cuff and doing his thing
in his background's insane and he's a
he's just different and that's why we
dig it now you start to lose a bunch
that's that that Stitch stick gets
really old but right now he's winning
doing his thing he's taking these short
notice fights you know fighting these
guys that aren't even ranked in the top
freaking 20 and he's you know he's
beating him for the UFC taters taking
out dudes left and right that we've
never heard of no he can pronounce that
they're really tough too he's just
melting these dudes so you know it's a
good story I'm a Sean Strickland fan I
really am he's a Savage all right let's
take a little break from chatting all
things UFC 2 90 this episode of the shop
show July 4th special is brought to you
by my friends at happy hippo the best
Kratom on the freaking planet and boy
are they giving you quite the
opportunity here because their July 4th
sale is going down all right and the
sale runs out on the July 5th so you got
it for 40 38 hours the entire site you
can mix and match you get if you buy two
products you get one free mix and match
uh you can do the K dips you can do the
gels you can do the gummies the powders
the instant shots which I use the
butterscotch or sour apple you can get
the k-nips the Kratom uh highly
concentrated shots and sour apple and
the k-nips mix and match buy two get one
free this sale goes on to July 5th it's
for 48 hours and you can save uh was it
20 off when you go to happyhippo.com
promo code is thick23 as usual thick 23
3 C's 23 you save 10 or 20 off the
entire website but take advantage of
this July 4th sale it ends on July 5th
again that's buy two get one free
site-wide mix and match whatever you're
looking for Now's the Time to get on it
because you're gonna buy two and get one
free at happyhippo.com July for sale is
here through the fifth get you some
let's get back to the program
uh but the UFC 290 is here it's the best
card we've had in a hot freaking second
the I mean the prelims are solid the
early prelims are good but that the main
card to take my money uh it starts with
uh
yeah it starts with the the bow nickel
the last of the great white hype bow
nickel
uh versus Gore uh this is if you've ever
seen a Jurassic Park when they're they
pull out the goat for the T-Rex that's
all this is I get and I'm all I'm I'm
always the biggest advocate of bringing
a guy up slow especially a guy's taunt
this bow nickel a big Prospect like this
y'all bring him up slow but this does
this is to me is it's no shame against
Gourmet it's just Bo nickels kind of a
once in a generational Talent
I I agree bring it up slow but this is
like a step back this is like Bo nickel
you know if this is a math test is in AP
Calculus and he's going back doing
subtraction like no we got to keep make
it more difficult to keep going this way
you see like nah let's just give him a
big win on this card that's all this is
there's no Rhyme or Reason Gore should
be fighting Bo Nick or I know Bo Nick is
only 4-0 and Gore's four and two two of
those wins they're counting from
Ultimate Fighter which I agree they
should count so he's sworn too but most
time they don't count though so his
actual UFC record is one and two against
a prospect like Bo nickel he's gonna eat
his dick like Kobayashi do he's gonna
eat him alive you know however he wants
however he wants you know however he
wants you know obviously there's the
helm area where Gore if Bo nickel does a
you know a weird takedown which is so it
just ain't gonna happen but he could you
know if he shoots in wrong he gets his
neck the guillotine's there outside that
weird Hail Mary this is a complete beat
down a bonic obvious submission under
two minutes I bet he gets him down early
if he wants but he could also his team
could also be like hey let's use this as
a learning experience get some cage time
let's keep it on the feet for the first
round or two and then when we decide get
them down now I think
to add more momentum to the bow nickel
train he needs to go out there and
absolutely demolish him in 30 seconds
that's what I would do forget your
experience you got all that wrestling
experience we'll work on that after this
hopefully they toss you a tougher
opponent where he can get some actual
cage time in but for this to build the
hype get a neck fight a big name next
fight we need to starch this dude if you
struggle with him or the fans or Dana
thinks that there's a competitive fight
they're not going to put you where you
need to go next so if I'm Bo Nick I'm
like whatever it takes as fast as we can
rent this dude's dick off
eat his dick that's all I do dude
uh so Bo nickel the uh however the hell
he wants to do uh but that'd be a fun
one it's always good to see a guy come
up like Bo nickel he's one of my faves
uh Jalen Turner Dan hooker my man Dan
hooker cannot get a uh easy fight I know
Stan hooker has all the experience with
my God man this is not a great fight for
him Jalen Turner is a mother trucker
dude his you know he's just he's good at
everything you just fight against gamrod
I just
it's tough man and some people had him
beating camera which says a lot you know
I I would say he outstruck gamrat
obviously the grappling was an issue the
takedowns
um but this this isn't a this isn't a
good one for him
damn our boy map for Rolla beat him
Steamroller beat him
but uh since that lost our boy
Steamroller he's been
he's won one two three four five five
out of six the only loss coming that
since 2020 was to gamra which was a
split decision a lot of people think uh
Jalen Turner won that fight it's it's
just a bad fight for our boy
it is and I love Dan hooker I love him
but Dan hooker is one of the good I love
Dan hooker it just sucks dude out of all
the matchups give him Jalen Turner
they're supposed to fight before I got
rescheduled I just don't like it for Dan
hooker you know he's a lot of miles on
him June Turner is a mother trucker dude
so yeah yeah Bo nickel Jalen Turner good
fight Dan hooker's never in a boring
fight where he gets you know just Molly
whopped but um Todd stylistically tough
[__] fight for our boy Dan hooker uh
how about this the third fire in the
card Robert Whittaker uh do policies yep
it's another one where obviously do
policies I think it's just the state of
Illinois division they're trying to find
fresh meat for uh Izzy the champ the
great Izzy the pound for pound Izzy uh
there could not be a worse matchup for
du policies in the middleweight division
I mean one through fifty they're gonna
be a worse matchup for him Robert
Whittaker to go hey duplicates you'll
get to Izzy but you gotta get through
Robert Whitaker first you might as well
just be like it's never happening it's
just a nightmare for him an absolute
nightmare I don't see in any facet how
he gets it done
uh if you and this no I I'm not I'm it's
not that I dislike you police it's just
it's very black and white if you're
being subjective here if you look at
duplicity's wins you know the Darren
till when Darren till could win that
fight definitely could have won that
fight there's times you thought there
until was gonna win that fight his coach
said it's a nose issue he had surgery
you know he's only breathing eight
percent which is all crunk of [__] but
hopefully his cardio got better but
there until there's definitely
opportunities for Dan till to win that
fight uh Derek Preston there was
opportunities for Derek Bratz to win
that fight
you know and if you look at Robert
Whittaker he hasn't lost since 2014 to
anybody but in middleweight to anybody
but the best is he nobody beats Robert
work unless she names Izzy it's not stew
look at his resume just go through a few
of the names uh Derek Brunson he
starched him uh jock Ray starched him
Joel Romero uh you all Romero twice one
of those was awful right
um Darren till uh Jared Cannon there
Kevin gaslum Marvin vittori and you know
he pieced up Marvin vittori man and
anytime he fights these guys it's not
very close either he's just a bad
[__] if there if Izzy was born
at a different time or Izzy was that
light heavyweight like Robert
Whittaker's one of the greatest if not
the greatest middle way to ever do it it
just sucks the day he was born the day
is he was born same time same same
weight class so you know he's the he's
the second best we got but boys it's is
he Robert Whittaker and then everybody
else Izzy is above Everybody by a
landslide and then Robert Whittaker is
above Everybody by Lance and then the
rest of the division that's just what it
is so Robert Whittaker is the best
middleweight not named Izzy of all time
I think hands down
probably gets this done would have to
give him a title shot against Izzy for a
third one I'm not mad at it I'd watch it
It's just tough when you've seen it so
many times you know yeah stuff on the
co-main event
um five rounder for the flyweight
Championship brand Moreno uh pantosia
pantoja's the bet I think the most
talented the best fighter to not be a
world champion on the roster
he is so goddamn good he's so good
um
is grappling the way he handles
transitions his aggressiveness he's a
bad [__] he now here's the thing
too he's beat Brad Moreno twice he beat
him in The Ultimate Fighter house and
they he beat him in 2018
via uh decision on that UFC Fight Night
Maya vs Kamara Usman and Chile
so he has two wins over the champ
now is this the case if he just says
brand Moreno's number I don't know but I
would say as good as pantosia is Brian
Moreno from 2018 has gotten a lot better
A lot world like Leaps and Bounds better
this confidence is up there he's been in
there at the highest level with the best
guys he's defended his belt he's lost
the belt he got the belt back against
him I mean figarito he's an absolute
monster
um you know fights against friend Roy
Val
um just juicier from Mega is kite care
of France he's just done the damn thing
man
he's a bad dude uh I just think even
though he's never got a win over
pantosia and I think most people would
say uh 2-0 dudes he has his number there
this is a little different because I
think you're dealing with a brand Moreno
who's a championship Brandon Moreno and
like Teddy Atlas says once you come
Champion it just gives you like a 20
boost in your skill set and your
confidence
um I think Bram Reno gets it done I
really do now that's saying a lot
because pantosia the one thing that
bothers me on this fight is Moreno does
when he's in scramble stuff he gives up
his back a lot and Pantoja with his
Jujitsu how good he is on the ground if
he even has a glimpse to get a hold of
Moreno's not get this one's over and you
have a new world champion from Brazil
right
um but I Bram Rayna knows that but it's
not
so crazy to say that
Saturday night you'll see 290 could be
an awful night if you're Mexican
for my wife or family don't tell them
this but it could be a tough night like
panto's just no [__] punk man this
isn't a walk in the park it's probably
not it's probably gonna go all five
rounds it could be super controversial
too like it they match up very well with
each other
um then yeah Rodriguez and Alex
volkanovsky in the main event
again it could be a tough night for
Mexican fans tough tough night very
tough night you have two mechs and lose
their belt like Gary Rodriguez says the
intern belt Ram Rhino has his belt at
flyweight I could either there's it's
not far-fetched to say Mexico goes 0-2
I I would say more likely brand Marina
wins I'm picking brand Moreno but that's
a tough [__] fight Alex volkanovsky
yeah Rodriguez
again I think volkanovsky what we saw
him do that lightweight after I saw him
compete against Market Chev at
lightweight I went oh there ain't a
featherweight on this planet that's
gonna beat that dude every featherweight
would watch that Mark Jeff I'd be like
oh Jesus Christ
there's not another guy at 45 who grow
up there and do that to Mach Chef
um
you know I do think volcanovski is the
best to ever do it at 145 hands down
he's the hands down the best ever do at
45. I I could see him winning that fight
against Mike Chev it was super
controversial decision to give to Mike
Jeff but still just he took Mike Jeff
down his success on the ground even when
much I've got him down he was never in
any big trouble would get back to his
feet see the strength of volkonovsky
volkanovski is like Matt Hughes and Tank
Abbott had a baby you know and he's just
tough he's the toughest guy to ever do
at 45. and I I think it's the difference
from back in the day to now the guys
back in there were just tough as Nails
man they weren't flashy didn't give a
[__] about Tick Tock and Twitter and all
this stuff they just fought and they
were tough as nails and volkonosity is
that dude with way more skill than those
gentlemen I mentioned way more skill
um I just don't see anybody beat him at
45. the shame is if vocal nasty decide
to make a living at 55 yaira
in ain't that a [__]
Rodriguez the best 145er not named Alex
volkonovsky there's a common theme with
this card here you know
but unfortunately Rodriguez he's born in
the same kind of areas you know
volcanovsky same time frame there was a
four years difference
sorry man yeah you're the best and to do
it at 145 not named voknowsky now yair
Rodriguez really does have in his
Arsenal is he can pull something off
whether it's you know uh unexpected kick
or vocal Nazi like you did against uh
Mark Jeff when he kept going the body
got caught coming up that could happen
and yeah Rodriguez just has the The
Knockout power to get it done uh with
one of those Hail Marys and he's always
dangerous so he does have that going for
him but I think nine times nine times
out of ten vocalosi beats the [__] out
yeah Rodriguez hate to tell you guys
but yeah it does have that you know that
Arsenal where the kicks can't really
train for his weird uh transition
submissions he has that weird X Factor
that you can't really train for so that
could catch a guy like volkanovsky the
odds are very low but he and that would
be the only way he wins he's he can't go
toe-to-toe with vocal notes for five
rounds to beat him if it goes decision
it's a landslide win for volkanovski I
think the first round or two there's
been a lot of feeling out with kicks but
no one closed distance better than
voknowski even though he's the shorter
Fighter by far I think yeah here's five
eleven but when obviously covers ground
better than anybody in the UFC so the
Height's not a big deal
um so I think it's been a long night in
the office right for Yaya Rodriguez
super long night
sucked I agree though yeah I don't know
how you pick against volkonowsky
the closer fight on the card would be
brand Moreno pantosia that's the closest
fight on the main card is Moreno
pantosha I I just
you know yeah Rodriguez surprised me I'm
a huge Rodriguez fan you know and my
household loves [__] yeah Rodriguez
but um
if you look at the if you go back to the
main cartoon yeah if you look at the
card it's it there's a lot of mismatches
there's a lot you know volcanovsky's if
he if he's checked in Focus doesn't get
caught with anything he should beat the
show yeah Rodriguez Robert wicker
duplici's awful matchup for duplici's
Robert wicker should mop the floor with
him
Turner Dan hooker's tough fight for Dan
hooker then Bo nickel and Gore to get on
my face you know it's just it is what it
is but she made a great night of fights
meaning you need some dope ass Knockouts
dope finishes if there's an upset hell
yeah it could be card of the year but
everything goes according to the way
Vegas odds has it you're gonna you're
gonna have Landslide man these fights
aren't going to be close except for bran
Moreno pantosia other than that these
are all landsites what are your thoughts
on Robert Lawler versus Nico price
what version of robular do we get is he
saying that this is last one for sure
that's what he said his last one you
know you got to be a goddamn communist
to root against Robbie Lawler you know
so tough fight for him you know but I'll
take Robbie Lawler and his you know his
retirement fight yeah
well how the Jimmy crew Alonso
Battlefield is a fun one yeah what are
the odds of it for uh
for Lawler yeah I assume he's a dog
yeah plus 25 versus minus 255 for Price
po nickels minus 1300.
that's when that's when you know you're
eating dicks dude when you're a minus
1300 and the UFC and the main card yeah
when's the last time
somebody on the main card was that big
of a favorite like it's it's very rare
that's how big of a prospect is but to
my point how this is a lot like this
main card a great card definitely buy it
it's phenomenal fights some big stars
and be some big knockouts
but if you just look at the odds so the
main card kicks off with bow nickel Gore
at bonic is a minus 1300 that's insane
then Jalen Turner Dan hooker Jalen turns
a minus 250. it's a pretty big favorite
man and then Robert Whittaker or
duplicis is a minus 410 that's a massive
massive favor massive favorite if this
was NBA or NFL the odds are never minus
410 but if it was you'd bet every penny
you have on the NFL team uh Bram Reno
pantosia to my point it's a little
closer minus 180 plus 55 and then Focus
Rodriguez again I'm not throwing any
shade at Rodriguez but fukurasi is a
minus 410 in a championship fight that's
insane dude that's how much better these
Champions are these the Robert Whittaker
is not Champion but like he said he's an
outline that middleweight division
there's just such outliers this is what
we're getting you're getting a guy who's
a minus 410 you're getting a guy who's a
minus 410 like Alex volkonowski and Rob
work are both minus 410. that's insane
odds insane so only way duplicies
duplicity I just I don't see how he wins
in any fashion I don't I don't see it
with the skill set
Source matchup of all time for the
middleweight division besides Izzy
probably
and then for yai Rodriguez if you're
gonna bet on a dog he's probably your
best bet because he does like do
policies don't have that X Factor where
he has an explosive spinning kicks or
these weird jumbo kicks the knees the
The Guillotines the triangles yeah or
has that so if you're in bed on a dog
you can bet on the helmet of yayo
Rodriguez and vocalopsy having some slip
up or something hasn't seen yair pulls
it off but other than that this it
should be called you know UFC 290 UFC
290 favorites guarantees yeah UFC 290s
eating dicks
damn
good card though it is it's a lot of
mismatches yeah that initial bone nickel
guard minus 1300's like okay that's more
than Holloway Korean zombie
yeah yeah that's pretty crazy well
because the reason why that's lower is
because Halloween Korean zombies mean no
grappling so they're like all right well
someone came but he caught Beau Nichols
such a good wrestler like well if he
wants to he's just gonna take him down
and beat him in three seconds yeah
that's why the odds are that way
but yeah it's a it's a good ass card
it's just a lot of mismatches besides
bran Moreno pantosha it's what it is man
let's take a little break last break fam
last break before we finish breakdown
UFC 290 this episode of the shop show is
brought to you by audit audit
supplements but not just supplements on
it nootropics the best nootropic on the
planet talking about Alpha Brain they've
sold over a million freaking bottles
worldwide a million freaking bottles of
nootropic that's how good it is here's
the thing if you've never tried it give
it a shot they will refund your money if
you don't love it no return necessary
keep the Alpha Brain share with a friend
who's not so ungrateful but if you do
love it they have so much for you man
because this nootropic Alpha Brain you
have Alpha Brain Black Alpha Brain
instant the regular Alpha Brain Alpha
Brain shots you got all I prefer the
Alpha Brain Black that's what I use on
every single show AIDS and mental
processing it's caffeine free helps you
get to that flow State promotes Focus
support your memory you can think more
clearly under stress react more clearly
they got it all man so go to audit.com
save 10 off everything all the on it
Alpha brains the instant the shots the
Alpha Brain Black you get temperature
off all that then also got the best
nutrition on the planet we're talking
about protein powders creatine
multivitamins uh the shroom Tech the
total gut health they got it all the
Summer's here it's a thick Boy Summer
but let on it help you lose and shed
some of those pounds they have on-demand
workouts you got streaming Fitness they
got steel Club maces kettlebells battle
ropes they got everything you need so
your acid is so thick go to audit.com
shop get 10 off let's get back to the
program
all right
also
Alex Bahia posted this on his Twitter
and this is him watching Sean Strickland
win I guess they're homies now they
train together yeah they train together
yeah so I but the thing I saw in this
video that was interesting was the dude
I'm sure he's just like you know
whatever
physical therapist or whatever but the
way he has his hand on his his left ass
cheek and he's just like massaging
wait people have a problem with this no
no I personally just saw this and I
started laughing I don't know why it's
like on his hip no but his uh his left
hand's on his uh his ass on a tip really
it's weird huh
it was just funny to me on her he's
rubbing his rib or whatever yeah and
there's like ointment you can kind of
tell yeah I mean it's like uh
yeah for me it was interesting it was
funny so interesting
um all right let's go actually let's
start with okay this this sucks so Henry
suhuto I guess he messed up his shoulder
so he's out of the fight with Cheeto
Vera this is what's weird is
like the problem is Dana announced it
and then sahuda was like no I'm not
ready like my shoulder's not good he
announced it and they're just not
checking it's just stupid to put the
pressure on tejudo and he's like nah I'm
not good man I can't fight I'll try nope
I can't like why not check with these
guys re-announce it I mean that's what
they do though right so he said
unfortunately doing my right shoulder I
won't be able to fight I've already torn
my left shoulder where I was out for
about a year I don't want to tear
further than what it already is that
being said there's a tear there the
cat's out of the bag it's actually a 50
tear yeah 50 so if he would have fought
Cheeto tears it even worse you know it's
probably that's probably career Ender so
he's being smart about it it's just
weird that
the UFC would announce they're like oh
damn I think this has to do better for
Cheeto I didn't like that fight for
Cheeto and we love Chino here of course
yeah
uh so someone I guess a fan would suck I
don't know if this is like legit but
this is a moment when Henry was doing a
breakdown of the fights and then he you
I'll just play for you real quick
[Music]
the way he hits like he goes this way
and then he's throwing elbows oh I just
hurt my shoulder
um he goes you know what I mean like
he's definitely not when he tore it no
but I'm not sure but little movements
even like coughing
it's gonna be terrible it's definitely
injured it yeah is that what they're
saying they're saying like oh no yeah
that's good for an eagle in the real
world no that's not how it works and
this is uh cheeto's response to the oh
by the way so Cheeto is asking for Peter
Yana Peter Young that's who you should
have been fighting yeah but this is his
response to uh so who don't not doing
the fight
well
[__]
he's the best well [__] what are you
gonna do I know yeah he's the best
yeah he's great
uh this we talked about it was a rumor
before but now it's official UFC says
that shafka rank Mana versus Kelvin
gaslin yeah my initial reaction like
Jesus Christ turbo fight for Kelvin
gaslin that is terrible but then when
you think
about it I mean Calvin was supposed to
be a world champion he had world
champion written all over him he's just
a little on discipline he's always
should have been fighting at 170 because
what he's doing for this fight yes so
this is back at 170. if it's a good cut
for Kelvin it's a good fight if kelvin's
being disciplined and he's focused and
he's doing it right and making the right
weight cut Calvin at 170 is a bad
[__] man but if it's the Calvin
that's depleted and doesn't want to be
in there you know then he can get murk
the undisciplined one but it seems like
he you know he's older more mature he's
talking about how he's made a lot of
mistakes and he's learned from those and
Calvin at 170 that's 85 even though he
was a bad dude at 85 you look at his
fight with Izzy one of the best to me
top two middleweight fights of all time
and that's at 85 he has no business
being at 85 he's too small it's just not
the weight class for him he should be at
70. so if it's a good cup for him kill
him Gaston's a bad dude at 70.
all right so
for UFC 290 Sean Brady was supposed to
fight that awesome dude from Australia
Jack Della madalina I know but Sean
already had some really messed up things
elbow yeah
that's his thing I guess there's it's
called strep infection streptococcus or
something like that but his elbow got
inflamed like crazy like build up fluid
so I got to get out of that fight
um here's some pictures of it um
yeah it's pretty crazy
but um so Kevin Holland actually said he
would step in without a catch weight for
Jack Della that would have been me uh to
me that would have been the fight to do
and I'll just play this from Kelvin
from Kevin Holland and by the way he
uses this thumbnail which I'll get to
this story after this of uh Paula Casa
and Tracy Cortez
um and I'll just play this for you real
quick
oh they're saying
they're saying for 170 185. well I think
I'm the perfect candidate I used to
fight at 185 and now I actively fight at
170. look
we all know I can make 185 one week and
then 170 a couple weeks later you guys
are talking about damage and this and
this and that in the third well like I
said before there's a good chance
Michael kiesta might pull out the fight
anyways so I fight jacket 185 Fiesta
pulls out it's no longer a big deal and
Castle stays in I then go in there and
do a grappling match against kieste at
170 pounds a couple weeks later this is
nothing this is like all sticking to the
diet and all sticking to the script a
bunch of Striker one's a Grappler I
think it makes perfect sense you guys
are all worried about Jack but be honest
with you I don't think Jack touches me
for 15 minutes Jack's one hell of a nice
guy but he's talking about fighting
we're not talking about nice people here
again and give it a little second here
and this here there in other nudes
Apollo class is a complete Savage I'm
done oh there's
so we'll get to that stuff but I mean so
I wish they would have done that fight
they didn't though they put out some
other dudes so Josiah Harris he's
undefeated was he 7-0 7-0 so he's legit
but he's not from the UFC he's coming in
from the LFA
but uh yeah I think Holland would have
been the fight that would have been
amazing but he does have to fight kids
in three three weeks they're not gonna
do that because that can because let's
say he goes in there it's a tough fight
for both of them man it's not gonna be
an easy night in the office so let's say
you get speed up then they gotta find a
replacement for gas and that's [__] up
to Kia so that's why they don't do that
but I wish it would happen
yeah okay so I'm bringing this up
because it is pretty popping in MMA News
right now but it is just sort of like
you know it's just more you know
[__] stuff so uh I didn't know this
but Brian Ortega and his ex-girlfriend
Chase Cortez they broke up at some point
I didn't know that yeah well I had no
idea yeah but then Paula Costa posted
this picture with him and her
um on it says happy Friday and I used to
date what's up did they used to date who
Holocaust yeah I don't know Cortez I
don't think so but because Paulo Casa
does have like a girlfriend or yeah now
yeah yeah yeah so he posted this and
then people went crazy you're like Brian
you dropped the ball this and that for
sure and then so Brian I guess he got
tagged so much that he had to do this
little post so everyone out here talking
about I fumbled you all must not know
the rules of the game when you drop the
ball in accent that's a fumble when you
throw it away on purpose that's called a
completed pass top G [__] yeah so he did
you know say something about it and then
Tracy Cortez wrote this
she's talking about Brian right here
yeah she's like literally yeah no no
yeah people can't people says so Tracy
responds to that was let me just say to
this day I've yet to say anything
negative about your bash your name Don't
Start Throwing Shade now I'm blessed
and then it got to this point where
Paula Costa posted this on a Saturday so
the first post was Friday and he just
shows his random girl's ass that he's
grabbing on a Saturday and people are
assuming that it's I mean I'm sure Paulo
is wanting this to well yeah no [__]
[__] yeah that's why he's doing it so
then I looked it up to see his
girlfriend or his wife and then that
that's his girl and then I saw her like
actually respond to one of the
commenters the commenter said like oh
he's hooking up with that Tracy Cortez
person he goes no the only person who's
he's hooking up with is this beautiful
manager because she manages yeah she did
delete that comment though and then uh
Apollo just pulled posted uh afterwards
most beautiful that's cool in the planet
so it's a dumb thing but it is like
popping yeah I know it's news for the
reason yeah
yeah yeah it's just real housewives at
UFC right it's just the drama in the UFC
yeah it's weird and polish has been
popping on the internet like crazy
that's what he does like he crushes it
on there
you know what he's doing
uh this is a quick boxing one so Canelo
Alvarez he wanted to I guess he was
going to fight the one of the Charlo
Brothers
he is fighting the trailer bro yeah so I
think the original one was I always mess
up the names of jermal he was supposed
to fight yeah Jamal and Jamel so I think
he's supposed to find Jamal first but
then Jamal had some personal issues so
Jamel
stepped in to do the fight he wanted to
do it on Mexican Independence Day but
since Dana White apparently got all the
different venues that Canelo wanted to
do and that date he has to move it
towards uh September 30th instead of
September 16th oh which is Mexican
Independence Day
yeah it's just a question because Canelo
always fights on there but I don't care
why they can't do them the same you know
because I think Canelo wanted that
particular venue with the in Vegas in
Vegas T-Mobile yeah so probably like it
would have been the best option but he
always does it there too that's what's
weird I'm surprised that the the
T-Mobile went with well I mean it's the
UFC they're gonna run it and they're
killing it right now too so yeah true
what do you think about this this is uh
Jorge Mazzio's organization it's like
Jorge bare knuckle MMA and he just
booked a Junior versus
yeah bare knuckle yeah good for Jorge
man massive fight dude he had like great
because they're supposed to I thought
this can go down in bare knuckle but
well this is bare knuckle MMA yeah but
it's different this is on uh Jorge's
yeah yeah there's bkfc which is just
bare knuckle yes the Jorge does MMA with
bare knuckle and they're doing MMA bare
Knuckles oh damn that's why it's better
I think
for these guys especially forever Doom
yeah because it's Jiu Jitsu is insane
tough fight for JDS
of course yes yeah oh yes looks insane
there no picture I think his head is
just massive I feel like they're both
probably like
they're good they could do whatever they
want now oh yeah yeah
it's like good luck beating that thing
that dude's a monster but that's good
yeah they're later in their lives too so
it's all good yeah I love Purdue man
all right so this was kind of big news
in the beginning so it's the report was
from TMZ that the Italian government
actually requested uh the Coliseum
be a place that Mark Zuckerberg and uh
Elon Musk fight at which would be you
know historical for obviously historical
yeah these two [__] [__]
yeah yeah the guys that lost their lives
in the Coliseum just fighting like lines
and [__] are like are you [__] me
2023 this is what we're getting
so what happened after this is like uh I
guess the Italian government responded
later saying that no we didn't you know
there's nothing on paper there's nothing
I never believed anything I'll be very
clear like and I think even jail came
out I was like Marcus Zuckerberg hit me
up I heard that's all [__] you made
that up I'm sure yeah and then even like
all these like rumors like the Italian
government I was like why would the
Italian government trying to get this
because they want the money obviously no
but it's just not the the government's
not going to do that like no countries
I'm like we want it here it's just not I
don't think that's real however so okay
after that happened Elon Musk did tweet
this of course
that happens in Coliseum and then uh so
once the the representatives from the
government responded uh the original
people that had you know the sources
that they got the information from they
said that no they they did literally
reach out to Zuckerberg and they're
supposed to have a meeting like sometime
this week or something who who run the
Coliseum yeah yeah
so I mean I don't know which one to
believe but I I can totally imagine them
reaching out and saying like you know
let's have a talk yeah I guess I is
anybody else sick of this [__] it's like
what
like you see the products
obviously I don't think it's going to
happen but if it does happen it would be
insane it'd be crazy yeah yeah it would
be I just think and who knows what's
real anymore but didn't elon's mom like
no you know she had but I mean my mom
would say the same thing I would I would
fight still khabib doesn't his dad was
like you're retiring after three yeah
he's retired died uh the Klitschko
brothers the mom was like you're never
fighting they both retired well some
people are different than us actually
respect it's not a piece of [__] our
Christian's like yeah but it's a mom I'd
still fight okay well some people
actually have respect for the parents
and if the mom says no especially like
if you're if you're elon's mom you're
like what are you doing dude a trillion
[__] dollars yeah and it'd be one
thing if you were like if your son's
down and out like has to do this for
money or you know which would suck too
bills no it's different it is different
but it would stop you're fighting for
your kids food or something like that
but what are we doing here I know but I
do I I still don't think it happens if
it does it's just gonna be insane do it
do it in the the Coliseum but just have
it that don't don't have the UFC like
Fighters involved in it don't just have
it this weird gimmick like one-off don't
have like other fighters on the card
that's what they should do
yeah and it says something like if they
did fight in the Coliseum the government
would say that it would have to be a
non-violent fight so I don't know what
the hell that means well to me
non-violent no matter how they fight it
doesn't mean no either from The Eye Has
the strength to hurt the other one you
know oh gosh you'll see more
entertaining fights on World Star but
it's just because these two Rich dudes
want to fight for their egos people like
oh this is sick I mean they're
yeah they're doing what they should be
doing putting themselves in the news in
the media
should they be doing that Chad
for what for their businesses more
attention
for what though it has nothing to do
with their business yeah but there's
more attention to them than people are
looking it has nothing to do with their
business it just doesn't bring more
value to Twitter which or the boring uh
company that he owns it doesn't I think
more attention will bring more people to
your businesses that's just what happens
how much more attention do you I know
they don't need it Facebook is the
biggest platform in the world and by the
way these two guys they're super like
they're they're not just super rich but
they're super famous they want fame too
I already noticed this it's just
something yeah
it'll help them grow their their face
it's not going to help their companies
you think people are going to watch Elon
Musk and Mark's like I need to sign up
for Facebook no but I think the more
it's like some people don't even use
Twitter some people don't even use
whatever so if they get to know that you
know these guys are fighting these head
of Twitter head of whatever it just it
just exposes you to that stuff that you
would not have been exposed but so what
what
I don't use Twitter but what column of
America and you're gonna use it if you
watch this fight no I'm just saying
it'll open my eyes what what people are
gonna tune in the fight culture what
people are going to tune into watch two
men fight that weren't aware or didn't
already have Facebook accounts already I
hear what you're saying yeah I got you
say this is like your business this one
this is where I'm out this is where I
won't entertain when people go oh this
is for it's a good business move or
they're doing for charity it's like
that's how you know this is a gimmick
and y'all are falling for it it's two
Rich dudes who are jumping the queue
with egos yeah that's all this is
there's nothing else to it that's all it
is it's not for charity it's not to grow
the Twitter Facebook platform it's it's
all this is it's two Rich dudes who have
the power to do it and they're taking
advantage of it that's all this is
it's gonna be the worst fight you've
ever seen of course that's a great fight
we'll watch it but I don't yeah I don't
think Elon that even Elon or Mark was
like man I bet I could get some more
subscribers to Facebook yeah but so let
me ask you this though let's say like
you right now you wanted to
Fight The Rock which we talked about
before right if you fought the rock I'm
sure there's people that are not aware
of fighting the kid they're not aware of
the Golden Arrow they're not they're not
aware of shop show they would have a
little bit more interest in what those
times are completely different no but I
mean it's I'm nowhere near I know but
it's the same concept it's not though
because you're you're talking about so
do you think the rock would gain more
followers by fighting me
maybe yeah are you [__] me how big
he is but there's people that
probably aren't fans of him right now if
he beat you in a fight there's not dude
if there's not there's a level at the
level that they're at yeah there's
they're there they're on the top of
Mount ever what I'm saying all it can do
is go down there's no more going up
they can't gain more Facebook followers
you're telling me if the rock actually
which he's not going to be able to do
but if he beat you in a fight like
literally beat you up in a fight he's
not gonna get more people no
he stays exactly the same I completely
disagree he's too famous already I mean
of course he's super famous but still
what if you beat the Rock in the fight
you're getting more followers yeah but
you're comparing me to Elon Musk The
Rock and Mark Zucker I'm just looking at
one of us has something to gain the
others have nothing to gain okay we can
disagree on this but that I those guys
are so famous they're the everybody in
the world knows who they think they
would just lose followers that I don't
think it gets gained puts more momentum
in their business in any faster
who's gonna be like is that I've never
heard of this Mark Zuckerberg he
performed really well I'm gonna sign up
for Facebook we all know Facebook
already know the majority of the world
knows let's break it down not sign up
for so he's gonna follow you right okay
so you gotta you gotta take me out of it
too and that's real okay so Zuckerberg
Zuckerberg destroys Elon Musk right I
don't follow Zuckerberg on Instagram or
Facebook or anything right or Twitter
I'm sure there's people that are fight
fans that be like oh [__] he's [__] up
Elon Musk that bad they're more
interested Facebook account so then if
he no no if so they follow Zuckerberg
Zuckerberg has like I'm sure plenty of
things he does on business-wise right
even let's say merch people will be
buying that stuff too you don't think
that Mike trickery doesn't have merch
I'm just saying 60 billion dollars he's
not creating merch he's not us chin I
think he's that he's at such a different
level we think like this okay he's at
such a different level everyone knows
who he is every you could go anywhere in
the world everyone knows my mom doesn't
know who he is she knows what Facebook
is she knows what Facebook is my mom yes
I guarantee your mom that's her Facebook
by the way even even if he won the fight
she wouldn't know she wouldn't even know
but the majority of the people
especially people that tune in let's say
let's say it does something we've never
heard of let's say it does 50 million
pay-per-view buys 50 million
how many subscribers are on Facebook
billions
it's the biggest social media platform
in the world by far it's not even close
billions so it's just a fraction of 50
million paid for that pay-per-view it's
still not gonna add value to Facebook
let's say a hundred million I'm not
saying necessarily Facebook but he does
other stuff like metaverse [__] and
all the other stuff that he does like
who does the oh no that's Apple art the
goggles that's Apple okay never mind but
yeah just I'm sure he has other
businesses and people will be more
interested in him and let's say he wants
to do a jiu jitsu thing or whatever more
people are interested in him it might it
might be good for it's gonna be the
opposite more people might be like
more Jiu Jitsu Community might be a fan
of him but then I'm gonna sign up for
Facebook man I've never heard of this
it's not necessarily Facebook anyways
we're gonna disagree on this it's fine
yeah I I don't see the plus side for
them at their level like when you're on
top of Everest
you know it's just like you're there
there's they can't get any bigger they
can't get in both neither one of them
can get more famous or bigger that's why
this is interesting that's why people
are like oh this is cool they have
nothing but just to lose here they can't
get any two of them cannot get any
bigger it's like Putin
famous as [__] dude poon took a fight
he's not gonna gain more followers
Russia's not gonna become cooler
there's certain people that are in this
Stratosphere that you would never want
to be in they're so high up there's
nowhere for them to go dude they're
they're up there there's the only way
they can go is down all right there's
nowhere for them so you're saying that
you're not on the level of them which
okay that's fine I know I know real
quick I get it I get it dude
level of Fame I'm I'm down where the
Titanic's at all right they're they're
up at you know within Mars that's the
difference between how famous we are so
we can at least agree on this I'm sure
if you destroyed the water The Rock
which you would probably I mean you
would do you would destroy the Rock in
an actual fight that would help you
would get that that would help Brendan
yeah so you because at this point
because I'm not flying at their house so
you're saying at that level I'm I'm down
in the ocean bottom right now all right
we're good it helped me out but when
they're both that famous it's like it's
like Brad Pitt George Clooney okay
yeah fellas you know
it's at that point it's just a risk for
them
now they might get they might get some
uh people like yeah good for them for
doing that you know but that's it they
have nowhere to go unless so unless Elon
comes out like head kid chaos them
then then that's really gonna [__] up
Mark Zuckerberg now he's not going to
lose subscribers on Facebook his
business isn't going to go down there's
nothing to do with it do you think ahead
check here from Elon Musk right heck
kicks out Zuckerberg like crazy you
think that'd be the most watched do you
think knockout
do you think more people would be sports
but would you think more people would be
more inclined to buying something
Tesla's or Tesla stock has nothing to do
with zero no because the especially the
people at that level of that business
negotiating they're like this is
barbaric like they're knocking like that
I want I'm I'm gonna vote for that guy
what the [__] he's doing you know all
right
I get what you're saying but I I just
don't think it works out that third
level you're saying it at that Threshold
at that there's nothing else they can do
there's literally nothing I'm cool with
that I'm cool with that
all right so this is cool but it also
sucks at the same time so Tyson Fury
this is not guaranteed but apparently uh
Frank Warren who's Tyson Fury's manager
he said that there's something crazy in
the you know that's gonna happen with
Tyson Fury it's going to be like you
know game a game changer in sports so
the rumor is that they're going to do an
uh an exhibits exhibition boxing match
with Tyson Fury and Francis Gano where
it's not guaranteed but they couldn't
have any knockdowns or something like
that so it's an exhibition which would
suck yeah
so that's what the rumors are right now
so I think Eddie Hearns one that uh
what's the point exactly so there's no
Knockouts there's no like no knockdowns
real fighting so it's an actual it's
exhibition Tyson versus Roy yeah yeah no
that would not be the way to go for sure
and that's also not gonna sell at all
yeah at all hey come check out these
guys like move around a little bit dude
that's the worst thing they could do
yeah it's gonna be an awful mistake for
Francis man when you leave the UFC think
you're gonna get this big fight like
we'll do it but we can't actually hit
each other that's what we want to see
they'd be better off doing the WWE like
you get more eyeballs that fan base
knows the deal they train for it they
look good you get that WWE fan base
doing a fake boxing match it's it's
gonna turn all fight fans off yeah so
you're not getting that support WWE fans
don't give a [__] mess with doing WWE if
you're gonna fake it
no okay
so yeah if that happens that sucks if
it's not a real boxing match
I honestly I would rather watch Elon
Musk and Mark Zuckerberg fight then this
is insane then Tyson fear and Francine
got to do a fake box to match yeah
well that's where I'm at I'd wave way
rather watch the Zuckerberg Elon Musk
regardless what all right so I'm kidding
oh over Tyson Fury if it was a real
fight of course no yeah I'm like damn we
gotta fire each other
it's just different opinions
um so I didn't know that Barry Bonds was
doing Jiu Jitsu but apparently he just
received his blue belt for
for uh
jiu jitsu
and I'll play this clip here I looked up
the guy's name I don't know the the
actual place do you know this guy John
Jay involve yeah evolve John Jay Janeiro
honey or whatever it evolves a big chain
I trained to evolve in uh Brazil that's
cool
I just didn't even know he was even
doing Jiu Jitsu but yeah that's pretty
cool
and I think that's pretty much it for
current events those were good man cool
dude
that's it that's it all right kids UFC
290 this freaking weekend headliner
volkanovski Yari Rodriguez brem Moreno
Pantoja Robert Whittaker duplicies Jalen
Turner Dan hooker Bo nickel the great
white hype first Gore is going down
Robbie Lawler's retirement fight if
you're not buying this card you just
don't like fighting yeah it's a bunch of
mismatches and there's a lot of
favorites on there you're gonna kick
some faces and eat some dicks but it's a
great card definitely tune in
um that's it kids love you guys Happy
July 4th be careful those fireworks if
you're actually doing the old school
type of Celebration but uh Happy uh July
4th and uh yeah man tune in like
subscribe share with your friends love
you guys be safe out there happy July
4th I'm out